it serves what you were just touching on
their sherry I mean how many films do
you think are killed because producers
are so adamant that their film has to
have a theatrical run meaning that they
turn down distribution if it's not going
to have that maybe you know they're so
adamant that it has to play theatrically
that maybe they hold the film back or
that you know they they squander certain
opportunities in hopes that okay that
this is a theatrical phone it's going to
speed that and they're just so stubborn
about it that um enough time passes all
the metamaterial previously that that
kind of thing right yes I I do think
that coming in with totally preconceived
notions that are selfish motivations not
anything related to the realistic
prospects that your film has can be
extremely detrimental I mean I've seen
people coming to me out of the woodwork
whose films have been out ready in
played festivals in 2008 and now they're
starting to think about what can I do
and I go that film is five years old now
I mean it's known to be five years old
you had reviews at the festival's it
says on IMDb your film is five years old
it's really gonna be hard to now try to
launch it out into the market a five
year old film that nobody heard of much
then but for sure has forgotten about
now so not to be so rigid in your
thinking about how is the right way to
put your film out you know be open to a
lot of different opportunities but then
you also there's also that balancing of
I'm just going to put it on every free
to watch site in the world and then I
want to have a broadcast deal or I get
an offer for a podcast I'll accept that
I did this other thing and now that
negates in so you have to it is really
hard it is really hard to make a
decision about which is the right way to
go I think part of it is as making sure
that the film is as strong as it can be
and I
a lot of people don't do enough test
screenings outside of their personal
circle people they they just show it to
their friends and their cousins in there
and the people who worked on the movie
but they're not going to give you the
most honest answer what you should be
doing is filling a room with 10 or 15
people who are in your target audience
but don't have a personal stake in
seeing a success of the film and don't
even tell them that you're the director
or the producer that this is just a
group that's coming together to watch
this film that you know you you have and
and take on board what they have to do
more than one you know but really think
about if enough people are saying a
certain thing it's definitely worth
paying attention to and do this before
you start sending things out to festival
you know to you really want to have the
strongest piece that you can before you
put it out for judgment in the industry
because they often won't go oh I recut
it and here's another cuttin you you
played that hand and they're not there's
so many people behind you that they have
to look at that you may not get that
second chance so you want to make it as
strong as possible but you want to be
open to all the opportunities like i
said to you have a plan B so that if you
do have that big premiere and the deal
doesn't come or the deal comes and it's
just not very good you have an
alternative that just gives you leverage
you know when you go into that
negotiation go hey babe I don't need you
I have my plan and I know what I'm gonna
do if you can up that if you can build
on that let's see it but otherwise I'm
not just taking this boilerplate thing
you're sliding across the table at me
cuz I know what I have I know that I can
I have ways to get it out without your
no advance partnership offer that you're
pushing at me and Ava Duvernay wrote
about that with middle of nowhere you
know she said I went into Sundance and I
had my date I knew when my phone was
coming out now we entertain offers I did
have a sales agent cuz I thought if we
get offered something that's better than
that we'll just take the money and give
it back to the investors you know we
won't we won't spend it but it's there
and I have it and I have a plan and it
even maybe that that's what you want to
negotiate with your
your distributor you know I have my plan
can you work within this I I can do
these things on my own but I need help
with these things can you bring that so
you're very specific about what they're
going to do and how much is going to be
spent remember whatever they spend they
have to recoup before you see any money
after that so you don't want it
willy-nilly spending as much as possible
because all that has to come back in
before you get any money also you don't
want them spending nothing you want to
know what's your plan I have my plan
what's your plan you know and there's
and so few distributors are being are
used to being put on the spot to know
that which to me is very bad business
practice you buy up titles but you don't
know what you're gonna do with them I
don't know where did that come into
practice but it's very common you know
for them to go well we don't release
that kind of information well I don't
sign an agreement until you tell me what
art what's put it in writing whatever
you're promising putting in writing you
know and if you're not willing to do
that you're not a good partner I'm not
turning my baby over to you and trusting
you with it because you don't know what
you're doing you know you don't know
what you're going to do but you can't
have that negotiation if you aren't
ready to walk and and have another
outlet that you've already set up
you